From creature features to gritty war
stories, these movie series have been
cranking out low-budget sequels
for a surprisingly long time.
A divisive crucible of infernal frights,
Clive Barker's directorial debut "Hellraiser"
is regarded as either a miracle of
movie horror or an overly bloody mess,
depending on who you ask. Is it possible
for both to be true? Regardless of the
film's quality — which is mostly fine —
"Hellraiser" is undeniably visually striking,
debuting Pinhead and the Cenobites in
this gnarly vision of industrial hell.
But if there's any debate about the quality
of the original, there's little to none about
the following nine sequels. "Hellbound:
Hellraiser II" is a pretty good time,
but after that? They're awful in
all sorts of interesting ways.
"We have such sights to show you."
Want an anthology film that was edited into an
incoherent mess? Try the fourth installment,
"Hellraiser: Bloodline." An unrelated script that
was grafted onto the series with little relation
to what came before? Try the incredibly poorly
named "Hellraiser: Deader." The series didn't go
direct-to-DVD and truly off the rails until the
fifth installment, 2000's "Hellraiser: Inferno,"
but sequels continued — and we also got a less
soulless and more thoughtful remake film in 2022.
Released in 1990, Tremors is a classic creature
feature that you've probably stumbled upon while
flipping channels across basic cable.
Starring Kevin Bacon and Fred Ward as a
couple of handymen in the down-and-out town
of Perfection, Nevada, it's an engaging and
charming film featuring some very memorable
tunneling worm creatures with appetites for
human flesh. With such impressive talent and
solid practical effects, it's no wonder that
"Tremors" spawned a whole direct-to-video film
series — and even a short-lived television show.
Though Fred Ward returned for 1996's not-bad
"Tremors 2: Aftershocks," succeeding entries
saw diminishing returns. Whether it was the
introduction of flying raptor variations of
the series' monsters in "Tremors 3: Back
to Perfection," or a forgettable western
prequel set in 1889, none of them ever matched
the explosive fun of the original. In 2015,
a fifth sequel was released co-starring Jamie
Kennedy — and that one isn't all that terrible.
Though the quality of the films may be uneven,
it's quite admirable that, throughout all these
installments and even the TV show, actor
Michael Gross always shows as the absurdly
well-prepared survivalist Burt Gummer. The fun
that Gross has in the role is simply infectious.
All you really need to know about the
original Leprechaun, released in 1993,
is that a pre "Friends" Jennifer Aniston is in it
— a fact the marketing team got a lot of mileage
out of on the film's eventual DVD release. These
movies have always been schlock amongst schlock,
puzzling at best — has anyone ever
found leprechauns to be scary? Still,
the teams that have worked on the various
"Leprechaun" films at least deserve credit
for hitting every single horror movie trope
setting over the years. The Leprechaun went
to Vegas. The Leprechaun went to space.
The Leprechaun went to "the hood," — and
it was actually pretty good. The Leprechaun
then went "back 2 tha hood," and it was not.
A seventh installment, the first one
without original star Warwick Davis,
crawled out of the direct-to-video gutter for
a brief theatrical release and near-universal
rejection in 2014. That still didn't stop
the leprechaun from returning in "Leprechaun
Returns" four years later — but Davis didn't
appear in that one, either, and it aired on the
SyFy network. It seems this leprechaun hasn't
seen a big pot of gold in quite some time.
"And now you're dead."
The original "Jarhead," released during the
height of the painful and questionable Iraq War,
was a gritty, realistic, personal movie about
the private hell of armed conflict. It wasn't
marked by big explosions and combat, but rather
the existential angst and terror that comes
during the moments in between. It was all set in
a surreal sandy landscape that would be beautiful
if it didn't invite so much dread. Directed by
Sam Mendes in collaboration with legendarily
talented cinematographer Roger Deakins, the
movie is gorgeous, stark, and unlike any war
film you've seen this side of "Apocalypse
Now." It's simply great, plain and simple.
And then there are the sequels, nine years
later. From the director of "Lake Placid:
The Final Chapter" and "Company
of Heroes" came "Jarhead 2:
Field of Fire." Then there's
"Jarhead 3: The Siege" and "Jarhead:
Law of Return," which were so bad they're
barely worth talking about — so we won't.
If the Brendan Fraser "Mummy" trilogy was like the
hit TV comedy ensemble "Friends," then the spinoff
mythology series it gave birth to, The Scorpion
King, is like the "Joey" of Egyptian-flavored
early-2000s action-horror. Introduced in 2001's
"The Mummy Returns," the Scorpion King was a
hulking silent heel played by Dwayne "The Rock"
Johnson in the early stages of his acting career,
back when people still weren't sure what he was
capable of. Though the movie wasn't reviewed well,
the Rock earned positive attention as a "Conan
with charisma" figure, and he has since built a
career in Hollywood off of that initially
underestimated reputation. Surprisingly,
the franchise he kicked off is still chugging
along as well, with a style that seems to get
more busy, more golden, and more like a "Mortal
Kombat" knockoff with every successive go.
The 2017 remake of "The
Mummy" may have been a flop,
but could things be different for "The
Scorpion King?" We'll just have to wait
and see — but if the answer is no,
we're not too broken up about it.
"Nothing lasts forever, my king. And
that is the destiny of all kingdoms."
Fans of the science fiction film "Starship
Troopers" may be unaware of how old the
franchise actually is. The source material for the
epic tale of man vs. giant alien bug was a 1959
novel written by Robert A. Heinlein, while the
first adaptation of the story was a 1988 six-part
anime. Meanwhile, the 1997 film has built a legacy
of controversy, analysis, and debate thanks to its
sharp and biting satire. Regardless of it all,
"Starship Troopers" has become an unstoppable
franchise that extends to the present, with
a reboot rumored to still be in development.
There is a surprising amount of
"Starship Troopers" content available,
including video games, an animated series, and
five feature-length films. The first two sequels,
"Hero of the Federation" and "Marauder,"
were direct-to-video projects. "Marauder"
managed surprisingly decent reviews,
thanks to the return of Casper Van
Dien as beloved bug-killer Johnny Rico. Two
additional animated films, "Invasion" and
"Traitor of Mars," are must-watches
for only the most die-hard of fans.
There's nothing in the rules that says a dog
can't play basketball — and there's no rule
that says that same dog can't spark a massive
franchise in the process, either. From its humble
start in 1997 as a feel-good family movie about a
canine athlete and the boy who befriends him, "Air
Bud's" evolution was slow at first. There was the
traditional sequel, released in theaters, in which
the dog plays football. In the new millennium, he
learned how to play soccer, baseball, and finally
volleyball, all of which made sense to varying
degrees. This could have easily gone on forever,
until someone had the brilliant idea to leave the
sports behind — as well as anything resembling
reality, In 2006, "Air Buddies" introduced
talking dogs — and suddenly, all bets were off.
Over the next seven years, the buddies
faced some serious snow, went to space,
did Halloween, made a lateral career move
into archaeology, gained superpowers,
and met Santa. "Santa Buddies" then split into its
own universe, with a prequel called "The Search
for Santa Paws" and a sequel with a surprisingly
serious subplot about a widower and his children.
The world of "Air Bud" is honestly one
of the most confusing cinematic universes
out there. The last "Air Buddies"
adventure was released back in 2013,
but there's still time for the
buddies to broaden their horizons.
"Broaden our horizons?! We're lost in space,
dog! I think our horizons are broad enough."
The original 1997 "Anaconda" film, about an
over-sized snake terrorizing a documentary crew
in the Amazon Rainforest, was a forgettable
project released amidst a barrage of killer
creature movies including "Bats," "Deep Blue Sea,"
and "Lake Placid." Although it boasted an all-star
'90s cast including Jennifer Lopez, Owen Wilson,
Jon Voight, and Ice Cube, the film has been
generally panned for its cookie-cutter characters
delivered with half-hearted performances. Despite
being nominated for six Razzie Awards, the
movie did well at the box office against a
moderate budget. Of course, Hollywood could never
leave well enough alone with the snake movie
that exceeded expectations — and they didn't
hesitate to bleed the creature feature dry.
"Anaconda" offers an unnecessary four sequels,
with the second film in the franchise, "Anacondas:
The Hunt for the Blood Orchid," being the only one
released in theaters. "Anaconda 3 & 4" were filmed
back-to-back for release on the SyFy Channel in
2008 and 2009. Finally, the fifth installment,
also a made-for-television production, involved a
crossover with another ongoing creature series in
"Lake Placid vs. Anaconda." As misleading as the
title may be, the Amazonian snake does not fight a
body of water, but rather the giant crocodiles
from the similar franchise. But "Anaconda"
is still not done: as is the case with so many
other '90s franchises, a reboot is in the works.
The original "Home Alone" is a cherished
Christmas film beloved by audiences of
all ages. Everything about the first film fell
perfectly into place: it was written and directed
by cinema legends John Hughes and Chris Columbus,
it featured a young charismatic Macauley Culkin,
and it even had an unforgettable score
from composer John Williams. Somehow,
these creators were even able to recreate
the magic with the sequel "Home Alone 2:
Lost in New York." Unfortunately, "Home
Alone" was not a gift that kept on giving.
"You got any more?!"
Many fans of the
holiday classic may be unaware that the
"Home Alone" franchise now extends across
six movies — some more forgettable than others.
1997's "Home Alone 3" was fortunate enough to
feature a script from John Hughes, but it was
otherwise a broad departure from the originals.
Where the made-for-television "Home Alone 4"
went wrong was in its decision to recast original
characters like Kevin McCallister and the Wet
Bandits without anybody from the original films
taking part in the production. The fifth film,
"The Holiday Heist," was equally forgettable,
even if it did have Malcolm McDowell in it.
When Disney got their hands on the franchise,
more effort was put into the direct-to-streaming
sequel "Home Sweet Home Alone." Unfortunately,
the critically-panned sixth installment
ultimately destroyed the chances of the
potential Ryan Reynolds-led, cannabis-infused
"Home Alone" remake, "Stoned Alone."
Long before superhero films were dominating
theaters across the country, "The Crow" was
one of the first successful projects based on a
comic book not named "Superman." Unfortunately,
the movie is entwined with the tragedy
of star Brandon Lee's onset death,
as he was fatally wounded while filming.
However, the feature received positive
reviews and has since become a classic for
its dark visual tone and production design.
The story of a resurrected musician
set on vengeance spawned an entire
franchise that includes three sequels and a
short-lived television series. Unfortunately,
each of the movies released
set the franchise further back,
culminating in the critically
derided "The Crow: Wicked Prayer."
Many fans still hope for "The Crow" to fly
to its former heights. Musician Rob Zombie
once intended to make his directorial debut
with "The Crow: 2037," while rapper DMX also
missed out on a potential "The Crow" project.
Thankfully, there is still hope for the franchise,
as a remake of the 1994 film, starring
Bill Skarsgård, is soon to be released.
Ground-breaking for its era, the original
"The Land Before Time," released in 1988,
was a children's movie with serious Hollywood
power behind it. Directed by animation legend
Don Bluth, it also featured Steven Spielberg and
George Lucas as executive producers. A moderate
success upon its release, the story about
a group of displaced young dinosaurs grew
to gigantic proportions, releasing new
sequels far beyond what was necessary.
The first "Land Before Time" sequel actually
wasn't released until six years after the
original — and neither Bluth, Spielberg, nor
Lucas were attached to the project. Regardless,
the franchise began releasing a new movie almost
annually until 2007, along with a short-lived
animated series that aired on Cartoon Network.
"Land Before Time" simply could not be stopped,
with "The Land Before Time XIV: Journey of the
Brave" releasing in 2016. Although rumored to
be the final film in the dino-sized
collection, it's easy to imagine the
"Land Before Time" franchise carrying on until
they run out of Roman numerals for the titles.
The story of what happened at 112 Ocean
Avenue has become more than a legend:
it's a paranormal dynasty that has outgrown
its humble beginnings. The original story,
as fictionalized in Jay Anson's 1977 novel "The
Amityville Horror," involves a young family
moving into a colonial home in Amityville,
NY before quickly being forced to abandon it
after some paranormal events. The original
book received its own literary sequels,
but nothing compares to the number of movies
spun off from the haunted residential home.
The original "Amityville Horror" movie
was released in 1979 — and since then,
there has been a smorgasbord of remakes,
sequels, and satires. There are so many
"Amityville" features that it is nearly
impossible to keep track of them. Obviously,
some are less faithful to the source
material than others — like "Amityville:
Karen," about an entitled "Karen" who
becomes possessed by the paranormal house.
"Oh s—!"
"You don't have a permit
to be jogging! These streets are made for cars!"
Regardless, it is safe to say that
low-budget "Amityville" movies are,
and may forever be, a consistent
element of B-grade horror.
The 2003 slasher film "Wrong Turn" was a horror
movie nobody expected much from. The story of
three cannibal brothers lurking in the forests of
the Appalachian Mountains who capture and kill a
group of young hikers, the movie did moderately
well both critically and financially. Of course,
any success for a horror movie instantly
means a sequel is on the way. However,
the franchise that was spawned from the
original film is nothing short of unexpected.
There are currently seven movies
based on the grisly story, the most
recent being the 2021 reboot originally
titled "Wrong Turn: The Foundation."
This latest installment reimagines most of
the tale, with members of a centuries-old
cult becoming the main antagonists. The other
five sequels featured the same horrifying
brothers — Three Finger, Saw Tooth, and One Eye
— who terrorized Eliza Dushku in the original.
Who wouldn't love a story about a troublesome
yet lovable Saint Bernard who wins over the
hearts of its adoptive family while causing
chaos around their home? What if they made
that into eight movies? And what if the dog
landed an acting job, uncovered lost treasure,
and was voiced by Tom Arnold? The "Beethoven"
franchise has certainly grown bigger than a
cumbersome pet since its humble beginnings
in the inaugural 1992 family comedy.
Originally written by celebrated filmmaker
John Hughes — under a pseudonym, as he didn't
even want to be associated with the project —
"Beethoven" was a charming film that managed to
rake in the money. So, of course, Hollywood
had to suck the beloved franchise bone dry.
It could be argued that "Beethoven's 2nd" was
a faithful and worthwhile sequel, but things
definitely went downhill from there. The third
installment featured a cross-country road trip,
followed by a fourth movie involving a collection
of new pet friends — and by the seventh film,
Beethoven was being dubbed over by Tom
Arnold and helping to save Christmas.
"You know, Beethoven, you must be really famous.
Cause it seems like every person that lays eyes
on you is just left speechless."
"Yeah, I've done a few things."
Much like the energetic Saint Bernard himself,
the "Beethoven" series is out of control.
This is one franchise that no one was asking
for — but it shot for the stars nonetheless.
When the original "Sniper" was released in 1993,
critics praised its fun approach to a classic
style of psychological thriller. However, it was
consistently noted as being unoriginal or shallow.
For the most part, it seemed like "Sniper" had
been discharged — until almost 10 years later,
when it came back for a sequel that formed
a B-grade franchise that simply won't stop.
There are now nine movies in the "Sniper"
franchise, with a tenth reportedly on the
way. Somehow, most of the low-budget films have
managed to maintain many of the stars from the
inaugural feature, including Billy Zane and
Tom Berenger. Still, each of the subsequent
direct-to-video sequels continue to be buried deep
in the bargain bin, with the latest installment,
2022's "Sniper: Rogue Mission," flying heavily
under the radar of most media outlets. Whether
anybody is watching or not, it seems as
if "Sniper" has many more stories to tell.
"Jaws" isn't the only shark movie that's been
run ashore with unnecessary sequels. Released 24
years after Steven Spielberg's classic, "Deep Blue
Sea" was another moderately successful '90s movie
that's perhaps best remembered for the scene where
Samuel L. Jackson is eaten by a gigantic shark.
"We're gonna find a way to get out of here!
First, we're gonna seal off this roo—"
For the longest time, "Deep Blue Sea"
remained a standalone project embraced
by action fans. However, Hollywood can
never resist a revival — and in 2018,
they began building a franchise out of
everyone's second-favorite shark movie.
"Deep Blue Sea 2" and "Deep Blue Sea 3" are both
direct-to-video films that carry on the story of
the genetically modified sharks introduced in the
first movie. Surprisingly, the sequels are adored
by fans and critics alike: in particular, the
R-rated "Deep Blue Sea 3" has earned itself a
respectably "fresh" Rotten Tomatoes score — even
if they did miss the opportunity to call it "Deep
Blue Three." There's no report of a fourth film
in the franchise quite yet, but somebody out there
just has to be planning a new installment
that's deeper and bluer than ever before.